I I somehow think liquid sword somehow
does it is like the most somehow become
the most underrated Wu-Tang album ever
because I feel like it it always gets
like [__] like yes like Trump when
people talk about like only Built for
Cuban links or 36 Chambers I'm like I
don't know Liquid Swords Liquid Swords
is amazing I just recently went back and
listened to it front to back so [__]
good man amazing album and it does
you're absolutely right I think that's
also because jizz is just very he's very
reserved yeah he's an introvert he
didn't have as big a personality as
absolutely as the other guys absolutely
that might be it too yeah I think that's
a lot of it too shout out to the Rizzo
man you ever tap in with a reason no I
met him recently
um but I never tapped him with him like
musically which it would be a dream come
true for sure absolutely I also feel
like he doesn't do a lot so be like if
you get a recipe exactly exactly what
are we doing here facts